the next president of the united states
of america
joe biden if the term come back kid ever
apply to anybody
it's joe biden except for the fact he's
77 of course
he's tried and he's tried to become
president i honest to god believe i'll
be the next president states of america
come on honest to god
it wasn't to be not in 1987 or two
decades later
but he might now be about to fulfill
that dream
if he is elected his first priority says
one british diplomat who knows him well
will be changing the tone at the top of
u.s government
i think he will want to re-establish
what he would call values and
principles and integrity to the
presidency he's been very critical of
the way in which donald trump
has done that i think he will want to
bring people back together as he keeps
saying whether that is domestically
or whether that is working with allies
around the world to try and solve some
of the more
complex issues we have to deal with joe
biden is promising a sweeping change in
style and substance at the white house
at home he must get covet 19 under
control before having any chance of
restoring u.s economic fortunes
he'll also invest two trillion dollars
making america's carbon emissions reach
net zero by 2050
and on healthcare he hopes to expand the
affordable care act
nicknamed obamacare abroad he says he
wants to restore the international
standing of the u.s
and relations with america's allies
repair ties with international bodies
like the who and nato
and re-sign international agreements not
least the paris climate agreement
hi how are you joe biden's life story is
well known to americans not least his
personal
tragedies losing his wife and daughter
in a road accident only weeks after
being elected one of america's younger
senators
sworn in at the hospital bedside of his
two young sons who survived
his supporters say that tragic past may
help him as comforter in chief
to a nation mourning the deaths of
hundreds of thousands from coronavirus
well i think the pandemic is the number
one issue and nearly everything else
flows
from that so handling the pandemic
ensuring that people are safe to return
to work
and that all the protocols which is the
centers for disease control and so on
and the federal government itself being
championing are actually put in place
and i think that will help with the
economic revival
as well as restoring uh if you like some
level of normal c2
to handling the particular the problem
of the pandemic
joe biden hails from a different age in
u.s politics one of bipartisan
cooperation
he hopes to bring some of that with him
to tackle some of the biggest challenges
of our time
the pandemic and climate a formidable
task for someone half his age but joe
biden's been written off before
multiple times only to come back
fighting
dominic waghorn sky news